prince george is definitely growing up
william and i are absolutely thrilled
the duke and duchess of cambridge's
eldest child
is celebrating his eighth birthday
tomorrow and in honor of george's big
day
prince william and kate middleton shared
a new photo of the not-so-little prince
the adorable snap was taken earlier this
month by his talented mom kate middleton
the little royal was enjoying his time
in norfolk sitting on a car while
wearing a navy and orange striped polo
shirt
in matching navy shorts he also sports
an adorable
and toothy smile we also have to point
out that prince george is william's
mini-me
yeah all very excited the almost
eight-year-old royal has been
pretty busy lately he recently attended
the euro finals at wembley stadium in
london with his parents
and george was one cue england fan
prince william loved it
george may have rocked a suit at the
game but that fancy getup
didn't stop him from jumping out of his
seats when his team scored a goal
england edging closer come on boys
says prince william of course england
ended up losing
italy in the finals so the duke of
cambridge was seen comforting george
although his home team lost prince
george is definitely winning on his
eighth birthday
prince william loved it
you